[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAJ KANNAN: Welcome, everyone.
My name is Raj.
I'm with Schlumberger.
I'm the-- got a
fancy title here--
DELFI Data Ecosystem Manager.
Today, I'll talk about
the petrotechnical suite
of applications and how we
brought them onto the Google
Cloud Platform, some of the
challenges that we face,
and how we worked with
Google to address these.
But before we start, let
me give you an introduction
to Schlumberger, particularly
for people who might not be
from the oil and gas industry.
We are the leader in the
oil and gas services space.
We have about 100,000
or so employees.
We are in about 85
different countries.
From the software segment,
which is what I represent,
we've got about 70,000
petrotechnical users
that are using this.
We have around 1,600 people out
of Schlumberger in the software
segment and about 800 different
individual clients that are
actually using this software.
So when I talk about software,
what do I really mean?
What are these domains?
And what problem
spaces are we tackling?
So if you look at the upstream
exploration and production--
that's what E&P
here stands for--
and the challenges
in the space, you
are looking at understanding
of the subsurface,
identifying of the reservoirs,
then on to the execution phase
in terms of drilling
and completions first
and then into production
and the operation space.
So our software
suite, as you can
see with the different
branding names down below,
goes across the spectrum, all
the way from the exploration
side into drilling
and the production,
not to forget the economics
aspect of things, right?
And there are some
infrastructural projects,
which I'm showing in the
last column, that are really
geared towards how do
we wrangle the data?
How do we bring the data
into these platforms
so the users can work
on that, if you will?
So a few years ago,
the industry sort of
hit a hard spot in terms of the
economic stress, if you will.
So the industry's goals really
changed, if you will, right?
So efficiency and the ability
to have cost control or doing
things in a much more
cost-effective way
than we had done before
becomes a key aspect for us.
And therefore, what
we were looking
for is how can we tap into all
of these cloud and big data
technologies, if you will, and
bring them into the oil and gas
space, particularly
in the upstream E&P,
and how we can tap
into this, right?
And traditionally,
where we've been strong
is the physics aspect
of things, if you will,
shown by the domain,
both in terms
of the human services that we
do in terms of data acquisition
or the execution of the
operations themselves,
but also in terms of
the software that we
provide to the various groups.
So effectively, this was trying
to marry the expertise that we
have in the domain
and the science
that we have within our software
and see how can we complement
this with some of the things
that these cloud technologies
can bring into this space.
So hence was born DELFI.
So this is something
that we commercialized
to the marketplace.
Last September, we had a
global forum, a similar event
with our customers in Europe.
And this was released back then.
So like I said,
the key aspect here
was to try to bring in
aspects around the cloud
in terms of the scalability, in
terms of tapping into the data
itself, right?
So there's so many things
that you can do with respect
to the physics side of things.
But when you are trying to drive
efficiency to the next level,
you want to see how much can
we do in terms of automation,
in terms of taking away the
mundane things, whether it's
the geoscientist, or
whether this is a reservoir
engineer or a
production engineer who
will have to go through on
a day-to-day basis, right?
So bring the data
science aspect of things
and supplement that with
the physics that is there
within our platforms to deliver
more in terms of efficiency
and bootstrapping the users.
So what I'm showing
on the far right
are the key quality attributes
that we were looking for
and what our customers
were looking for.
Obviously, as we are
tapping into the cloud,
we need to make sure that
the system is secure.
This is, in fact, particularly
the exploration space,
a lot of what our
customers are doing
and how one customer
differentiates themselves
with the other is in
the way, in the know-how
of how they are processing
the data, how they
are able to go through an
exploration phase, how they're
able to identify the reserves
properly, if you will.
So this becomes a key
differentiating factor.
So if data becomes a key
differentiating factor,
we are talking about the cloud.
Then the security aspects
becomes absolutely key.
And this is an aspect where
we've spent a lot of time.
So this is one of the
architectural principles
that, to us, is non-negotiable
exactly for this reason, right?
So everything else in
terms of functionality--
all the things below that
you see on the list--
comes after we made sure
that the system is secure.
Datacentric is what I
touched upon in terms
of being able to bring the
data science aspect of things
and then supplement that
with what our platforms are
able to do.
Openness and extensibility
becomes a key aspect.
So in our current
suite of applications,
we have a extensibility
platform that we call Ocean.
So these are a set
of APIs by which
our clients, third party--
in fact, there's a
lot of competitors
who have tapped into it, as
well, to bridge their offerings
into what Schlumberger has been
bringing into the marketplace.
So the same concept has
to extend into the cloud.
We realize that
our customers are
working on things that's way
beyond just the set of tools
and workflows that we are
going to be providing to them.
And the other aspect of the
cloud that we can tap into
is the collaborative and
the personalized aspect.
So unlike other
industries, this is a place
where you have people that
are working in far-flung areas
out in the field.
There are people
that are working
in the offices across
different countries.
[AUDIO OUT]
We are operating in 85
different countries.
So you can imagine the
challenge of distribution
and collaboration
that is necessary.
The expertise typically lives
in the headquarters, right?
So there are a few experts
that are centralized.
And then the rest of the
teams are distributed.
So how do you bring the
right personalized interface
to get them all to collaborate
and work together as a team?
So this becomes a key challenge.
And last but not least, a lot
of these things-- and, in fact,
there was an interesting talk
yesterday that I went to.
Arun from Baker
Hughes was talking
about what they were doing
on the machine learning side.
And he was talking
about uncertainty.
So this is a key aspect of
our industry and the challenge
because you don't get
to see the subsurface.
So there are
certain measurements
that we've done in terms of
well logs or in terms of seismic
or in some cases core
samples and things like that.
So there is little windows
of information that you get.
And effectively, you're
trying to build a model
to piece together the rest
of the blanks, if you will.
So as you start building
these layers of information
on top of each other, you are
introducing and compounding
uncertainties as you go through.
So therefore, the
ability to de-risk
this when we are trying
to take decisions
that make a big
economical impact
becomes really important.
And where we are tapping
into the elasticity
and the scalability of
the cloud is exactly that.
So instead of being
compute limited
and trying out the
few combinations
that I can try
out on prem today,
could I burst this
into the cloud
and make some decisions
that are more accurate,
bring down the cone of
uncertainty, if you will,
on the various parameters?
So I kept talking about
the different domains
and the challenges.
So I wanted to drill down
a little bit more deeper
and talk about the
different profiles of users
and what types of challenges.
And I'm trying to map this into
the IT or the infrastructure
speech so then we can try to map
it into the cloud technologies
can fit in, if you will.
So let's start off with the
petrophysicist on the top
and go around in a
loop, if you will.
So the petrophysicist
is typically
working with well data.
And given the boon, then
you all have probably
heard about the
stuff that's going
on in unconventionals and
shale type of workflows.
This now has brought
up a ton of wells.
Now you're talking about
hundreds of thousands of wells
and historical data
that hangs off of this.
So you're talking
about millions of logs
and potentially in the
order of tens of millions,
if not hundreds of
millions, in terms
of well tops and
properties that are
associated with it that have
been interpreted by the users.
So the ability to deal with
high-cardinality datasets
and be effectively acquiring
this, consuming this
from a computation capability
becomes a key challenge
for a petrophysicist.
And today on prem,
we are challenged
by how much you can scale up
the work station for a end user
or how much more we can farm
out in terms of a local HPC
and its compute capability in
terms of dealing with these,
right?
So a lot of the things that I
showed you in the data column
with our products
were really focused
on the high-cardinality
aspect of things,
so providing a data
infrastructure that
backs up what the
applications will need.
Then moving on down into
the reservoir engineer.
So like I said, the way we are
dealing with data in our space
is there's only a few
measurements that we have.
The rest is all built
on a digital model
that the users have
interpreted on.
So the reservoir
engineer is a key role,
where they are trying to
take data that is coming in
from the petrophysicist, the
geologist, the geophysicists,
blending them all together
to understand what
the reservoir looks like,
what the reserves in there
looks like, what the
properties in terms
of permeability or
fluid flow looks
like, so then we can start to
plan the drilling of a well
into the reservoir and then
find out how effectively we
can get the hydrocarbons.
So therefore, the ability
to do the de-risking
from an uncertainty
perspective and figure out
how many simulations
can we effectively run
to bring that cone down
becomes really key, OK?
And then moving on down
in terms of the flow--
assurance engineers.
So these are people that are
in the production domain.
So you can imagine, once
we have completed the well,
and the well is starting to
produce these hydrocarbons,
there is a mix of materials
that are coming in.
That will have potentially
an impact on the flow.
It will have an impact on the
lifespan of the equipment,
whether these are the pumps or
whether these are the pipelines
that we've laid out.
So the ability to measure and
monitor the various instruments
that we have put in, look at
this high-frequency time series
data, and be able to take both
control decisions in near time
and be able to understand the
longer-term impact so we can
then plan for either work overs,
or an alternative strategy
to improve the field
comes into play, right?
So this is where the production
engineers and the flow
assurance engineers come in
and the high velocity of data
that we'll have to deal with
from the various sensors that's
been instrumented.
So then moving on to the left,
the explorationists-- so these
are typically geologists.
But they are looking at it at
a much more abstract scale.
So how does an
oil company decide
if they need to purchase
a particular field?
How do you know what
the field is worth?
So somebody has to
understand the basin.
They have to understand
the prospects within that
and then define what
a given play is worth.
So effectively think about
this as the abstract sizing
before you can judge what
the reservoir looks like
and get into the more
technical analysis of this.
So therefore, these
are people that are
looking at very large areas.
The ability to
visualize the data
in all of these areas, the
ability to scaleably access
the data for this
wide footprint becomes
really important for them.
And that ties into
the geophysicists.
So like I said, the
first piece of data
that you probably get
into a particular area
is really the seismic data.
And some of the seismic,
particularly in the prestack
world, could be in the order
of terabytes to petabytes.
And in a poststack
world, it could
be in the order of
gigabytes to terabytes.
So how do you effectively
bring them into a space
where a explorationist
or a geophysicist
can zoom and pan in and
understand the area in a very
effective manner, right?
So this is where
they are actually
interpreting the seismic to
understand what sort of faults
are in there, what
sort of zones are
in there in terms of
horizons and surfaces
and so on and so forth.
And that leads
into the geologist,
who then has to take such
interpreted data that
is coming in from
the well domain
from the petrophysicist
and the seismic domain
from the geophysicist.
And then he is
building a model--
an approximation of
the earth so then they
can start to figure out what
the properties of the reservoir
looks like in this
particular area.
So a lot of our
customers are really
looking for a way to go beyond
models into actually natively
looking at the
data without having
to have these approximations.
But the models are
a way to come up
with a way to simplify
or wrangle the problem
into a manageable space.
But even there,
in the past where
this was in the order
of hundreds of thousands
to million cells,
it's now getting
into the billions of cells.
And therefore, you can now
imagine simulation type
of workflows where
the impact of what
is being produced or injected
into one model cell on one time
step impacts the
neighboring cell.
So there's a lot of
coupled value extrapolation
that our simulators
will have to do.
And at that
particular scale, that
becomes a real challenge when it
comes to both the data handling
and the compute capacity.
So if I want to shrink all
this into a few bullets
that we can talk about
in the 50 minutes today,
these are the top five things
that I wanted to summarize.
So the 3D visualization from
a geophysicist's perspective,
from a geologist's perspective,
from an explorationist's
perspective; the
multiuser collaboration,
and how do we bring all
of these domains together
so they are all looking
at the data the same way,
and they're interpreting the
same way, so there isn't a gap
or a misunderstanding between
the different domains?
How do we handle the
large cardinality
of data, particularly
in the well domain,
and the large size of data
in the seismic domain?
How do we support
concurrent simulations?
And last but not
the least, like I
said, because these
are global customers,
they are operating
across the globe.
How do we deploy these services?
And if we are now offering
this from a cloud perspective,
we need to think about
availability and reliability
and all the SLA aspects
that comes along
with it, because
they are now going
to rely on our service
for business continuity.
So the way we took the
approach in here was obviously,
we started building
a bunch of workflows
that we are tapping into
the machine learning aspect
of things and
trying to figure out
how we can provide some
of these interpretation
type of capabilities
using machine learning.
Look for patterns and logs.
Looks for patterns and seismic.
And then use that as a
precursor for delivering
some of the interpretation.
But the big challenge
that we ran into
is if we will now start to
offer some of these capabilities
on the cloud, but
then they are doing
the other 80% of
the work on prem,
now there has to be constant
data movement back and forth
for them to go from start
to finish from a workflow
perspective.
So how do we minimize
this impact for the users?
How do we take the applications
that they are using today,
also bring them
along into the cloud?
So effectively, you
are shifting the center
of gravity of a asset team or
a business unit of a client
into the cloud space.
So that's where the
petrotechnical suite in DELFI
came into play.
So this is effectively
taking our applications
that typically run on desktops.
Most of these are
windows applications.
We do have a few
Linux applications.
So this is where the user
interfaces, and this is where
the users are interfacing.
And then those rely on two types
of capabilities on the back.
One is around the data in
terms of app servers, database
servers, and so on and so forth.
And the other one is in terms of
the actual physics that's built
into our numerical simulators.
And that's what is
classified as engines.
So by bringing these into the
Google Cloud Platform, now
the user has one place to go.
The data is in one place.
So whether they are tapping
into some of these native DELFI
workflows and the native
capabilities in terms
of machine learning
and automation
that we are bringing in,
or in terms of continuing
their workflow in the
platforms or the engines
that they are used to, it's all
in the same environment, right?
So that was the
driver for why we
commercialize the
petrotechnical suite in DELFI.
So what does that look like?
So let's take the journey
of Patrick, for example.
So the first thing
that we figure out
is, OK, what is his profile?
So if he's a
reservoir engineer, he
logs in into the DELFI portal.
So this is effectively a
bunch of app engine services
and Kubernetes clusters
that are running in GKE.
And this is where we manage the
overall interface to the users,
if you will, right?
So from a user
experience perspective,
how we manage the subscriptions,
understand which client
that they belong to, what
data sets they have access to,
and so on and so forth.
And this is also
the place where we
have linked some of
the soft services,
meaning the human
services, whether this is
support, health, consultancy.
They want to acquire
new data, in which case
we can have our sister
segments come in
and enable them with
data acquisition
and so and so forth.
And effectively,
what the portal does
is after it has figured out
who the user is and understands
that in this particular case,
he's a reservoir engineer,
routes him to a
production environment
that you see on the
right side, where
we've got all of
his applications
and all of his data
storage, right?
And we know that
over a period of time
we need to continue to
update these applications.
It's not a one-time shot.
So therefore, from a
continuous integration,
continuous delivery
perspective, we also
create a lab environment.
So when there is a newer version
of these products that we try
out, if the customer has
additional extensions
or plug-ins and things
like that they have built,
they have one cohesive
environment where they can
actually test and validate the
full length doing workflow--
Schlumberger and
non-Schlumberger services
together--
and then qualify that to be
promoted into the production
environment.
The final visualization
of the applications
and how they consume
it, if you will--
the native workflows are
all just web interfaces.
And so effectively, it's
ubiquitous access to a browser.
For some of these desktop
applications that are really
relying on the
visualization aspects,
we use thin client
visualizations--
so effectively doing
server-side rendering
and then transmitting the
results back into the browser,
if you will.
So again, taking those
same five key challenges
and then zooming it down
into the petrotechnical suite
potion of DELFI, let's jump
into some of the details
and how we went
through the challenges.
So the first one is around
the 3D visualization, right?
This one is a key problem
for us because if you
look at how most
of our users work,
they have probably
dual 4K monitors.
This is where they are
sitting and interpreting
eight hours a day.
If you have now taken an
intensive application like this
and moved that
into the cloud, we
need to make sure that it has
the same level of performance
that they are used to
today on prem, right?
So just to give you an analog
to how we may watch a Netflix
movie, for example, you may
be sitting on a 4K screen
and watching a movie.
So it's a one-way
stream of data that
is coming in from the servers.
In this particular case,
it's actually a two-way.
And it's more than
one 4K screen, right?
Because every time
the user decides
to move, pan, interpret,
click, the application
has to react as if
the application was
running on a box that's
right next to him, right?
So the ability to work
around the challenges
that the internet
brings into this space,
right-- so whether this is
things like packet loss, what's
the bandwidth.
A lot of the customers,
and particularly some
of the locations where
they are operating,
there's no guarantees in terms
of the right level of bandwidth
that they may have.
So we need to make
sure how optimally we
can design the system
so we can deliver
the right level of experience
with the minimum overhead
in terms of the
bandwidth requirement.
And likewise, we also
have to think about
from a global
deployment perspective,
how do we put these
applications close enough, so
that way the overall latency--
I mean, assume that
the visualization
aspect, the
computation aspect has
no penalty if the
customer is, let's say,
200 milliseconds away?
So by the time a frame comes up,
and the customer clicks on it,
and the application reacts to
it, you're looking at a half
a second, right?
And it may not seem much.
But if that's what you work on
8 hours a day, 40 hours a week,
pretty soon that becomes
completely unusable, right?
So therefore, the ability to
understand where the user is
and bring the application
closer to where the user is,
so we can bring it within
a reasonable latency,
becomes a key deployment and
operational challenge as well.
So from a journey
perspective, where we started
was really on the K80s.
Pretty soon we
realized that this
was more geared towards
the computer rather than
the visualization.
And where we are now
is with the P100 GPUs.
And I will talk about the
different areas or the regions
where we have the
service deployed today.
And where we'll be
moving to is towards P4.
And this has been a fantastic
journey with Google,
where they've been
constantly helping us
through this journey.
There are a few issues
in terms of where
we are with P100s, because
P100s, even though technically
supports vGPU, is also
built more for compute
rather than for visualization.
So therefore, there
are still challenges
in terms of having to bring
our own in media grid licenses.
And when the machines, from
a Google infrastructure
perspective, go
through a migration,
even the machines
have to shut down.
So imagine if you are a user.
You are remotely accessing
one of these applications.
And a live migration
event hits, right?
So that becomes a workflow
issue that we are now
working with Google to resolve
this with the new P4 offering
that they are bringing online.
So this is a video that
I shot on my laptop.
And effectively, what
you are seeing here
is our application Petrel that
is being served out of Iowa,
in this particular case.
And I'm based in Houston.
So I've just shot it
in my laptop screen.
So it's a 4K screen
that's being served
across the continental US.
And we are getting anywhere
between 20 to about 30,
35 frames per second.
And anything about 20, then
the user's perception that this
is actually remote goes away.
It feels much more
local and immersive.
So the other
challenge, like I said,
was user are in
different locations.
How do we bring them together?
How can they work in
the space together?
So here I am showing
three different profiles
that are working together.
And in this particular
case, the client environment
was running out of
the South Carolina
region for Google from where we
were serving the applications
to these different users.
So this brings up a
number of challenges,
particularly starting with
the security side of things.
So how do we, out of all of
these users on the internet,
identify these users?
And how do we
identify that these
are the users that also
belong to the same tenant,
if you will, and
therefore can share data
and can collaborate
effectively together?
So the step one in that
was the authentication
and the authorization process.
So we spent a lot of time
with the Firebase team
and the Google
team looking at how
we can tap into Google's IAM.
So effectively, our users are
mirrored into Google's IdP.
There are a few
customers, including
Schlumberger's own
internal use, where
we have federated with Google
and where we haven't federated
with Google, we go through
a registration in DELFI,
which effectively creates the
users in the Google space.
That now allows us to do
a basic authentication
and get all the benefits
of Google's ability
to look for anomalies
and to validate
that the authentication
truly comes
from the user and the location
and the device from where they
are trusted to access
the applications.
And then on the back end of it--
and this is where the challenge
for the petrotechnical
suite comes in--
is these are
applications that are
running on Windows and Linux.
So they don't speak a
G-token or an Auth 2 token.
So effectively,
we'll have to bridge
the gap between a
internet-friendly
authentication token and what
the desktop applications truly
need.
So what we do is we have
a service called SAuth,
or Schlumberger authentication.
Think of this as a
handshake service
that once Google has validated
that this user is indeed
Patrick from Cardinal Oil,
we can then turn around
and enable an account and
launch the application
under the user's account.
And that's what
you see on the far
right by this thing that we are
calling the Tenant AD system.
So that shadow identity is what
we use, so these applications
don't have to worry about
cloud-based identities.
They can still happily work
in the traditional Windows
and Linux space, if you will.
So here's a video.
Sorry about the fact that
it's a little bit grainy.
I think once we imported it,
I lost some resolution here.
But what I'm showing
here is two users.
So the user [AUDIO OUT]
has two 4K monitors.
And I also opened up
my laptop in there.
So you can see three screens--
two 4K, one HD screen.
And then the laptop
in the front is
designed to illustrate
to you a user who
is remote, that is looking
at the same screen as what
the primary user is.
So back to the
collaboration workflow,
just like we are taking the
output of the application
and presenting it to
the user in Houston,
we can present the same
application interface
to a user that is
sitting in California.
So now this effectively creates
a virtual room, if you will,
where these people are looking
at the cameras the same way.
They're looking at the
applications the same way.
And just as an analog,
if you compare this
to a Skype or a Webex or a
linked type of remote sharing,
these are not really
built for the kind
of 3D acceleration
and the interactivity
that you need to
be able to foster
this kind of a
collaboration, right?
So this is the high
end of the spectrum.
And that's what that looks like.
So then jumping onto
the aspect number
three, in terms of the data
sets and the challenges there,
like I said, there is two
real extreme categories,
if you will.
One is on the large data sets.
So this could be in the case
of seismic terabytes of data
that we may have to bring
into an application space.
So what is the overall IOPS that
my storage system can support
to be able to deliver that
volume of data, particularly
in a random I/O pattern
into the applications?
And then off on the other
end of the spectrum,
remember the petrophysicist
and geologist type of workflow
that I was
mentioning, where they
are dealing with
millions of data
items in the wellbore domain.
And these are
really small pieces
of data but higher
cardinality of data.
So I'm sure you all have
had the experience where
if you throw, let's say, 10,000
files into a file system,
you can see how much
it slows down, right?
So the ability for file
systems and their ability
to handle both
large-file random I/O
and small and high
cardinality of files,
and how you deal with this
from a directory and a delivery
perspective stresses
out the system, right?
So today, what most of
our customers are using
are these really high-end,
purpose-built systems
from the likes of EMC or
NetApp and so on and so forth.
So now imagine trying to
bring this into the cloud.
So some of our new
solutions, they
have the advantage of tapping
into Google's elasticity
in terms of things like Google
Cloud Storage, and BigQuery,
and so on and so forth.
But what do I do about
applications that still
rely on a service file system?
How do you bring the same
level of performance?
And these are several hundreds
of man-years worth of effort
put in into these
applications to bake
the physics and the
user experience into it.
So it's not possible
to overnight
just revamp the storage
and then switch it
over to use a BigQuery or
a cloud storage, right?
So it's going to be
a journey, so which
means we need to solve this
problem in the interim.
So we looked at a number
of both open source
and commercial solutions.
Some of the things that I
haven't listed here-- we
looked at things like Aware.
We looked at NetApp.
The big challenge that we
had was getting the level
of performance that we need.
So particularly in
the seismic space
for the sort of visualizations
that you were seeing there,
we need close to 400 MBPS
in terms of throughput.
And it's not a single
channel throughput
because this is multiple
users that are concurrently
running these applications.
So you need multiple channels
of throughput at the same time.
So how do we go
about doing that?
So we did a number
of tests with Google.
And Red Hat was
the other partner
that was involved in helping
sort out the implementation,
if you will.
In fact, this was one
of those components
that we rewrote and rewrote
over and over again just
to fine tune it to
the right aspect.
So we ended up with ZFS.
This is a old
component from Solaris.
But in combination
with Google, we
were able to tune it to provide
the right level of storage
back end, if you will.
And the other aspect
is the memory.
So this is probably even
pushing Google to the limits
in terms of what a GCE compute
VM's infrastructure needs
to look like.
So as you can see, when you're
talking about remote graphics
and dealing with a larger
volume of data visualization,
we need a high-end GPU
to be able to do that.
To bring enough data into memory
and be able to visualize this,
we need a machine that can
give that user workstation
a ton of memory space.
So most of our users
typically have 1/2 a terabyte
or 3/4 of a terabyte on
their workstations today.
So how do we get
the amount of memory
that is necessary to
hold this data up and do
the visualization?
And then on the back end
of it comes the storage
and the throughput
that the storage
has to deliver into this.
So where we are-- and if you
see the picture on the top left,
we are maxing out the spectrum
of where we could be today.
So for a GPU-based
machine, today we
can go up to 208 gigs of RAM.
And again, we are
working with Google
to push that limit
even higher, getting
it closer to where
we need to be,
which is in the 1/2 a
terabyte range, right?
So today, it's a dichotomy.
You can get the high-end
machines in GCE,
but you don't get the GPUs.
So we need the GPUs and the
high-end machines, if you will.
And the other collaboration
that we have started on
is the Cloud File Store.
So this is a new service
that's coming in from Google.
So we don't have to be
bothered with the deployment
and the management and the
elasticity of the storage
solution that we've
put together ourselves.
So jumping into the
simulators, so like I said,
there is a bunch of physics that
we have baked into simulators,
whether this is in the
petroleum systems space,
economic space, flow
assurance, mechanics,
reservoir engineering.
So we have simulators purpose
built for each of the domains
and the kind of challenges
that those domains have.
And what we have done with
the DELFI offering on Google
is we are now offering that
cloud-based dynamic compute.
And what does that really mean?
Now, I don't have to
be worried about a job
queue and a fixed
HPC cluster size,
and how do we get a bunch
of reservoir engineers
to fit their workloads in here.
If a drilling rig is
becoming available,
and I need to make a decision
within the next couple of days
whether I want to
employ this or not,
I can go ahead and
spend the nodes that
is necessary not only to do
that once simulation but also
many, right?
So here's a illustration of what
a reservoir simulation looks
like.
So these are the model
cells that you see here.
And the two blue
sticks that you see
onto the left are the injectors.
And you can see that
as the simulation runs,
you can start to
see how the water is
pushing the hydrocarbons
out through the other wells,
if you will.
So this is one
simulation and how
you can go through it in time.
But what we are now able to do
with the Google infrastructure
is you can take that one
aspect of it and say,
what are my uncertainties?
What happens if the permeability
that I thought was 0.7
is actually between
0.65 and 0.75?
Could I run a whole bunch
of these simulations
for the variability in
my uncertainty spectrum
and understand what my P10
and my P50, P90 use cases
look like?
And therefore, I
can start to de-risk
my estimate of the reservoir
and the flow in a much more
effective manner.
So obviously, this gives
us additional opportunities
to optimize here.
So what I'm showing you here
with respect to the graph
is the white area of
the graph are basically
the nodes that are active
at any given point in time.
Anything that is
blue are the nodes
that are either being warmed
up or being passivated.
And the orange ones are
the ones that are idle.
And if you can't see the
blue and the orange ones,
that means we have
done a fairly good job.
And that is the
point here, that when
it comes to the elasticity,
we don't want to have computes
sitting there idle, right?
And the y-axis here is in the
order of tens of thousands
of nodes.
And you can see
how effectively we
are using the Google
infrastructure to map
to what the customer's load is.
So this brings
both the elasticity
that they want to de-risk and
deal with the uncertainties
that they are dealing
with, and also
bring the cost-efficiency
on the other side
so that you're not ending
up paying for a HPC
cluster for peak
capacity and having
to deal with the cost aspects
that are associated with it.
So that said, there are some
challenges in this space
as well.
So today, customers
have purpose-built HPCs
set up on prem.
And these are running
with an InfiniBand
back plain, if you will.
So effectively, because these
are MPI-based applications,
and they have to share
data for each time step
across these cells, there's
a lot of communication
that goes along, right?
So we've tried to optimize
this by trying to do a hybrid.
So where we can do shared
memory in cases where
the compute instances can be
co-located in the same node,
and in other cases, we fall
back to network communication
over MPI.
And Chris actually pointed
me to the multi-ping latency
that I'm showing you
here, because just
like everything
else in the cloud,
things are constantly changing.
So by the time you
publish a metric,
the metric is actually old.
So the numbers have
come down on GCE.
As you see in the chart here,
it's a little bit dated.
So the other one
that we did was we
compared this with
other cloud providers.
We compared this with
various configurations
that we can do on Google.
There were a couple
of features--
and we like to think that
Google did this for us.
But I think it's of general
benefit to the community.
So one is around sole tenancy.
So this ensures that we can
have a set of nodes that
are assigned to work together.
So therefore, we can
bring down the latency
of the internode communication
for nodes that are part
of that sole tenancy scope.
They also introduced the
direct word I/O, which also
shaves the latency quite a bit.
And more recently, with
the Skylake processors
and its effective use of the
cache and vNUMA, if you will,
we've effectively
brought it down.
So if you look at the
chart on the right side,
so this is the
performance variance
that I'm showing across the
different options, the very
first column being what
the really high-end
HPCs that the customers have on
prem, versus where we ended up
with the Google Compute
Engine, with the combination
of direct word I/O, Skylake,
and sole tenancy, right?
So we are extremely close
in terms of the high end
without having that huge cost
of deployment and maintenance
and whatnot, right?
So last but not the
least, so so far,
we looked at some of the
technical challenges.
Now, let's look at the
operational challenges.
And first off, a shout-out
to the SRE team in Google.
They spent a lot of
time with us trying
to help us define where we want
to deploy these services, how
we want to instrument these
services from a monitoring
perspective, how do we
define the right level
of service-level indicators
and service-level objectives,
figuring out the error budgets
so our operations team can
be more efficient,
and figuring out
what are the key problems
that we need to focus
on operationally,
rather than going
after every problem that's
going to pop up, right?
So today, from a
GPU perspective,
we are in South Carolina,
Belgium, and Taiwan.
We are working with Google to
expand this to other centers.
And the other regions that
are out there we can support
are 2D applications.
But we're waiting on the
GPUs for the 3D applications,
if you will.
So a few other things--
so this was a necessary
evil for us to solve.
I mean, if we went with a Google
Cloud Storage or a BigQuery
or whatever, the
advantage is Google
takes care of the
disaster recovery.
But when you overlay
a shared file system--
in this particular
case, a ZFS file
system-- across multiple nodes
and multiple persistent disks
effectively, the metadata-- so
the individual persistent disks
are taken care of by Google.
But the overall
shared storage setup
and the metadata
that goes with it,
we will have to take care of it.
And the good thing
was the ability
to have snapshots on the
persistent disks is something
that came with Google for free.
And it's very effective in terms
of the incremental snapshot
that it overlays and how
quickly we can restore in case
there was ever a fault.
So the other thing that we
did was around consistency
and reliability.
So this was a very
important learning for us.
On prem, we've gotten
used to the fact
that machines do not go down.
Disks don't fail.
There used to be a time
when blue screen of death
was your day-to-day reality.
But that's not the
case anymore, right?
So systems have become
much more reliable.
And therefore, the determinism
of the availability
or the performance
of a system has come
to the user as a given, right?
But when you're
dealing with the cloud
and with the number of
things that are moving,
your virtual stack is way deep.
We have to deal with the
fact that fault tolerance is
something that we'll have
to build into the systems.
Be able to switch over
into a different node
if, for example, a live
migration event kicks in.
And the ability for
the infrastructure
to allocate a
resource to you also
depends on the load on
the particular system.
So what I'm showing
here with the charts
is we started monitoring
what the variance looks like.
So if I ask for a VM to
be created, user comes in,
starts an application.
How long before the
application shows up for him?
And the more deterministic,
the less variance
we can bring into the system,
the better the user experience
is.
So this was a lot of work
that we did with the GCE team
in Google to bring down
that variance that you
see on the various aspects.
And this is around the
availability of the system
and being able to
continuously monitor this.
So that way, we can use
our few precious SREs
and operational teams to focus
on management by exception,
rather than having to
babysit these systems, right?
So we leverage
Stackdriver quite a bit.
So we monitor both the
metrics that are coming in,
and we also route all
of the event logs,
including the application
logs, into the system.
So in the past, if there
was a crash or a performance
impact on one of
our applications,
the customer has to
call us and let us know,
this is what happened.
And we have to ask
them, OK, what data set?
What did you do?
Why did this problem happen?
And now, effectively
what we've done
is we've flipped
support on its head.
Instead of support
being reactive,
it's now becoming
proactive, all right?
So by looking at
these logs, these
are now creating events
that trigger an alert
to the operations team.
So these days, by the
time the customer calls,
they are pleasantly
surprised that the operations
team is already aware of what's
the issue that's going on.
And they're actually
working on it.
So by the time
they call, they're
actually getting an estimate of
when it's going to be addressed
or what a workaround
is that will restore
business continuity for them.
A few more things
on the monitoring.
So this is application
usage and security.
So beyond what
Google does in terms
of protecting the cloud
and the infrastructure,
we do realize that we
have our own applications
and our own end points.
And there is extensibility
on these end points.
So what you see on the
chart on the right,
for example, is monitoring
all the failed logins.
So typically, it's very easy
to think about the things
that you want to monitor,
which is the good-day scenario,
if you will.
But we also have to
be very cognizant
when it comes to security
on the cloud to take
care of these edge cases.
So anyway, to summarize,
this is a journey
that we went
through with Google.
We talked about
the five challenges
and how we are effectively
leveraging both Google's
expertise in this area and the
Google Cloud infrastructure
to tackle these.
And this is a solution that's
been commercial for almost
a year now.
And even though I have only
covered a small portion
of the challenges,
hopefully it gives you
a flavor for what it takes
in the oil and gas space
to bring in our software
suite and bring it
into a cloud environment.
But on the positive side,
there is a lot of advantages
that our users have got
on the system already.
So we talked about the reservoir
simulation and the benefits
so far.
But you can see, both
on the petrophysics
and on the seismic
space, not only
with the petrotechnical
suite but also
with the other
analytical solutions
that we are bringing
in to supplement what
the petrotechnical
suite does, we
were able to greatly
improve the productivity.
And because Schlumberger
is also a big-time user
of our own software
for seismic processing,
consulting, data
delivery, et cetera,
we've also improved the way
we deliver our own services,
right?
So these are some of the
stats in terms of the benefits
that the Google and Schlumberger
partnership has brought
into the oil and gas industry.
And I will close tying
it back to the first way
that we started, with
the economical pressures
that the industry
is facing today.
The solution that we have put in
here with respect to automation
and bringing the
efficiency is greatly
appreciated by
the market, right.
So I think I'm
fairly out of time.
But if there's any questions,
I can either take it now,
or we can take it offline.
[MUSIC PLAYING]